hey guys welcome to nerding out this is
the show where us gamespot nerds get
together to talk about the shows that we
like and today we're talking about the
walking dead season 7 episode for
service let's jump in
alright guys let's talk about Rick and
negan Spencer yeah so that was a pretty
powerful episode of negan walking in and
basically showing dominance especially
when he came to the part of handing Rick
his a treasured baseball bat and I think
he all spiritual muckman yeah just use
hold on that for me I think what kind of
also sets the tone here for this as well
is that he's gonna need is gonna be
continuing to push Fricks button and I'm
willing to bet that it's going to ricks
eventually gonna snap and maybe get on
but it might take the death of a
character another character for that to
happen but lots of wait and see there's
a lot at stake when you snap here yeah
you have to hold it together as much as
you can pour Rick for a quick poor poor
everybody else I know everybody else is
in trouble right now yeah that's true so
let's talk about negan's approach Aaron
what do you think negan is still afraid
of Rick I think he chose not to kill him
but he doesn't know what Rick's gonna do
rick is definitely still giving him that
I'm gonna kill you eyes and he sees it
and he kind of led to go I mean Rick
just hoots looking at the ground and he
keeps threatening Rick over and over
again and it's funny because his old
sales pitch is like I'm the Chinese
finger trap of bad guys like the more
you struggle the more you get caught so
just just relax we have it happen yeah
yeah sure I mean he probably showed up
randomly at the wrong time because he
was afraid to get ambushed yeah oh
that's the biggest thing so I want to
point out how they could have at any
point just resisted and been better off
than they are and what's really weird is
negan negan set it up so they know like
he wants them to know he said something
to Rick along the lines of well you all
remember what the hell is yeah um but he
wants him to know like yo I just screwed
you guys over so bad that you guys are
never going to recover like they took
all the guns he took mattresses like
they're more screwed up now than they
would have been had they fought other
than you know dying and whatnot but but
the fact that they leave food and then
take just creature comforts
I I think that it's completely like it's
completely different than the way that
they anticipated the the or at least the
way that I anticipated the the
arrangement is going and you can see
that in everyone's faces that we had a
chance we had an opportunity to actually
fight back regardless what happened to
our other friends we could have held our
own but we didn't do it and that I think
is what really is kind of causing a
cinder within the group especially now
no meeting everyone's just looking at
him looking at Rick like oh my god we
why didn't you tell us we could have we
really could have done something big
here we could have done something about
this so I don't know it's tough yeah so
how is everybody doing Aaron let's talk
about everyone else yeah I mean rick is
just barely holding on to this group of
people you've seen Michonne off probably
practicing to assassinate negan and you
see Spencer hiding guns and not telling
anybody because he might want to make a
play for power in everybody's the people
with nothing to lose I think clearly are
willing to go down fighting in a weird
way Rick because he has a child as two
children actually he's got more to lose
than a lot of the rest of the group yeah
and so people under him might be okay to
die just stick into their principles and
their guns huge variance of responses
from the entire group you know you have
people that are planning to assassinate
obviously like Michonne is obviously
planning to assassinate negan and then
Rick takes that opportunity from her yes
Spencer planning to do whatever Spencer
is gonna do with those guns in a bag um
there's a little bag of guns this is it
good thank you had my guns and booze
yeah and lots of booze let's think about
Karl so he's one of the few that refuses
to follow orders and or let's talk about
the difference is with the comic as well
buddy so yeah Karl in the comics I think
actually kills one of the Savior's and
Meegan's like man I like you man you're
cool you can hold my bet um he doesn't
actually make him do that but he forms
is really weird bond with Karl that you
don't see that you don't see that happen
like I was expecting there to be this
intimate exchange just based on how
closely they are you know
they tie to the comic maybe that'll
happen later like maybe they're building
a relationship and they're gonna be like
you know like oh I remember you you were
the guy that was aiming the gun at boba
I don't know but like it was not as
close to the comic as I was expecting um
although I I did feel good that the
situation like happened at all like it
was like oh this isn't seen from like
comic and then it wasn't exactly what I
wanted but he was there you kind of
caught a glimpse though he and I caught
a little bit of a glimpse because negan
could have totally discipline at him he
could have chopped off my finger he
could have done something he didn't he
let him walk right and he let him just
been I was anger and you can kind of see
a bit of a twinkle in deacons on when he
looked I was like mmm that kid I don't
know about that kid though student
Carl's him how ya like we don't know
what he's going to do with him but no
there's an interest he takes strong
personalities and bends them to his will
and i think that with Daryl like he's
he's like dude Darryl punch me this dude
is strong if I can break this strong
character if I can break him and make
him mine then I have that power for me
you know and then with Carl he is
approaching him differently I'm not sure
why maybe he's a really great judge of
character or maybe he's just a
psychopath in a leather jacket I don't
know yeah we have yet to really
understand me again okay uh let's talk
about those beds like why did you earn
them why did you do that so I think it's
kind of a parent why again you know yeah
negan always wants you to be thinking
about vegan yeah I mean if you're
sleeping on a hard floor you're probably
thinking about negan anything and this
sucks and I gotta get negan something
maybe I get my bed back good point yeah
yeah all right let's talk about next
episode go-getters any predictions guys
well yeah Maggie's Meggie's pissed and
you actually get a glimpse of her being
at Hilltop and we all know that Gregory
the leader of hilltop had a major thing
for her and I I think she might be being
held there perhaps I mean she might be
being taken care of why we don't know
but given the fact how Gregor's track
record is with her it's like he could
easily be saying hey you know you owe me
now because I saved your life but then
we see the Savior show up their second
in command and they're pissed so funny
thing is she doesn't know that she's
supposed to be dead because that's what
Rick told negan so that could set up
something for you too
stress if she's like oh hey I'm alive
this is cool which could lead to why
they're there like maybe they're out
looking for or something maybe they're
not satisfied with Rick's answer so
negan is just trying to marry everybody
yeah polygamist it's gonna be awesome
negan Mary's everybody and that's what
you have to look forward to yes season 9
wedding the wedding so tune in for that
next week and for all things comics TV
and movies stick with gamespot universe